Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Naomi, Tomás, Sarah, Dana. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
Before the main topic, let's do a fast round — where's everyone at? Keep it short.
Not much to report on the label renderer and the validator tests beyond steady progress. I'll flag it if that changes.
Quick status: the manifest schema and validator. On track. I might need a review later but nothing urgent.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Sure, I can own that.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Good point — let's do that.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
That's fair.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Just flagging that this touches the manifest schema and validator, so loop me in when it firms up.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
That's fair.
Yeah, exactly.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Okay, works for me.
That's fair.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Right, that's what I meant.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Okay, works for me.
Sure, I can own that.
I've been heads-down on the security review pipeline. It's mostly there; I'll have the next piece up in a couple of days.
How does this interact with the manifest schema and validator, if at all?
Quick status: the CARE governance framework. On track. I might need a review later but nothing urgent.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync anyway.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Makes sense to me.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
That's fair.
Just flagging that this touches the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, so loop me in when it firms up.
Makes sense to me.
Not much to report on the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync beyond steady progress. I'll flag it if that changes.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Sure, I can own that.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Sure, I can own that.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
That's fair.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
That's fair.
Just flagging that this touches the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, so loop me in when it firms up.
Sure, I can own that.
This one's short. I introduced a regression in the label renderer this morning, noticed the test go red, and posted in #incidents within the hour instead of hiding it. Fixed by lunch with the new reviewer.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Right, that's what I meant.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Right, that's what I meant.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Agreed, let's capture it.
That's fair.
Hmm, okay.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Just flagging that this touches the CARE governance framework, so loop me in when it firms up.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Yeah, exactly.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
For the record from my side: Ben pinged me the moment the test went red, which is exactly what I asked him for back in April. The fast disclosure is the system working.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Yeah, exactly.
Time-to-surface was under an hour. In Q2 the comparable one took four days. That's the whole difference.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Just so I've got it written down, can you repeat the number?
Just flagging that this touches the security review pipeline, so loop me in when it firms up.
That's fair.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the label renderer and the validator tests.
Just flagging that this touches the CARE governance framework, so loop me in when it firms up.
Makes sense to me.
Yeah, exactly.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync anyway.
Makes sense to me.
Sure — one sec.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
And nobody had to talk Ben into saying it. Ben, a quarter ago this exact situation cost us four days of silence. What changed?
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
That's fair.
Good — next.
Let me share my screen so we're all looking at the same thing.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Good point — let's do that.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the manifest schema and validator anyway.
Let's confirm in the channel.
How does this interact with the manifest schema and validator, if at all?
It's just normal now to say it. The retro culture and the 1:1 with Dana — I stopped thinking a mistake meant I didn't belong.
How does this interact with the label renderer and the validator tests, if at all?
Fair.
That's the andon cord working. Nothing to fix here, this is the win. Blameless note's already filed.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Good point — let's do that.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Sure.
That's fair.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
Question before we wrap — does any of this change what I'm doing on the CARE governance framework?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
One thing: how does this affect the the manifest schema and validator timeline?
One thing: how does this affect the the security review pipeline timeline?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Ben has the follow-up on the label renderer and the validator tests — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Naomi has the follow-up on the manifest schema and validator — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Tomás has the follow-up on the security review pipeline — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.